All righty, Joel, let me ask you this to start this one out, okay?
Have you ever been to the Golden Corral?
I don't think so.
Really? You've never been to Golden Corral?
No, I think I've only seen their TV commercials.
It's like one of those 3 a.m. commercials that you're like...
Dude, so recently, I hadn't been to the Golden Corral maybe like, you know, three or four times in my life.
And then we recently started going a little bit.
That place rocks, man.
You roll up in there and there's like a whole buffet.
Anything you want, you know, just classic American mentality here, you know?
And that, Joel, is kind of like what we got today on the pod.
Because we have a smorgasbord, a buffet of different research and news to talk about today.
That was the wildest transition you've done ever.
Not digging my intro? Not digging it?
No, that was great. That was great. That was crazy, though.
I had no idea where that was going.
Hey, man.
The Golden Corral.
We started Golden Corral and we ended up podcast.
Takeaway number one from the podcast today.
All right, man.
Dude, we got a ton of...
I mean, we probably have 12 different things we got on the list today.
So I don't know if we'll get through all this.
But tell you what, let's not go in the order we have in the doc.
Let's talk about this Port Swigger Research release first.
Because whenever Port Swigger Research comes out with something new,
gosh darn it, it's going to be a banger.
Bro, this was actually the best timing ever because I was testing something.
And specifically, I needed a URL validation bypass.
Yep.
And I was like, hey, this is extremely topical.
And I just plugged it.
So for those who don't know, before I get ahead of myself,
Port Swigger came out with a new cheat sheet.
So they have all these cheat sheets where basically like, you know,
I think calling it a cheat sheet is a bit of not really doing it justice
because it's more like an interactive payload generator, I guess.
Yeah.
Where basically, you know, they have these for various other scenarios.
Yeah, the XSS one is phenomenal.
I think that's probably the biggest one that I'm aware of other than this one.
I'm sure there's other ones.
But the XSS one is great.
You basically just say like, I'm on this browser and I'm in this element type.
Give me every payload.
And it'll say, okay, you can do on key down, on key up, on load, on hover, on whatever.
Right.
So that's really awesome.
They also made one now for URL validation.
So essentially, you can put in the target domain that it, you know, passes validation.
You can put in the attacker domain that you're trying to get to.
And then you can set different things like URL encoding, Unicode escapes,
whether or not to use special characters.
There's IPv6, IPv4, like all these different things.
And it's out of list.
And you just copy it to your clipboard.
And you can paste that in Kaido.
You can paste that in wherever.
Burp, I guess I should say.
Yeah, I guess we should say.
Sorry, Fort Swingle team.
It's your product.
We should lead with Burp this time.
Paste it into Burp.
Yeah, no.
But I, yeah.
But as far as I know, yeah.
Can you paste into Burp?
Or do you have to?
I think you can.
I'm pretty sure you can paste from clipboard.
But anyways, yeah.
So basically you just, you get a list of possible options.
And you can just paste this into your proxy of choice.
And test all of the different bypass options.
It's so nice.
It's really, really awesome.
It's really good.
It's nice because it allows you to specify an allowed domain name and an attacker domain name as well.
So you don't have to like do these like, you know, said commands to like pop in your domain.
And then sometimes they're like encoded a little weird so it doesn't do it.
Like it automatically does all of it, which is super awesome.
And then there's various advanced settings as well, including like various IPv4 to IPv6 transformations, cloud metadata endpoints.
Just tons of stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So very, very cool.
Very awesome tool.
It also has built into this.
It's not just for absolute URLs, right?
So like maybe it's for an open redirect or something like that.
But it's also for host headers.
So maybe you're trying to get access to an internal tool.
You're trying to do some vhost bypass.
They have host header generation for the same type of stuff.
So basically you put in the allowed domain, the target domain that you were trying to hit.
And it'll generate you a list of host header options.
It also has cores options.
So very, very awesome tool.
They made a little blog post about it as well.
If you're curious about sort of the background behind it.
But I'm sure if you haven't seen it on Twitter already, you can find the link down below.
But yeah, very, very helpful tool, especially if you're trying to bypass some URL validation, parsing, open redirects, SSRFs, you name it.
This is so, so pretty too, dude, because you hover over each one of the URLs, right?
Just hover over those and you'll see a, like a name or a bypass, like categorization for this specific why this works.
That might be new.
I don't think that was there when I first tried this, but this is awesome.
Safari allows left parentheses as subdomain HTTP colon slash slash allowed dot left parentheses dot attacker slash that.
Yeah, these are awesome.
This is, this is like, it's like the marriage of, of Shazer.
Yeah.
And like, I don't, I don't think this is, I don't know.
Shazer and cheat sheets.
Like the fuzzing side of like Shazer where it's like, you know, browser specific stuff and all these weird quirks and whatever combined with just like, I have this thing and this thing, get me there.
Yeah.
Well, I was looking at it though.
And it's, it's, you know, obviously released by Portsmouth Research, but it's created by D4D and it's linked down at the bottom of the, of the cheat sheet.
Um, but so it's not even Gareth and, and there is like shout outs to Gareth.
Like it says in the, the, the, the big thanks to section.
The first one on the list is there's a lot of names on here.
I think next time I make a tool, I'm just going to shout out all the people that I like.
Yeah.
Hope that they're like, Oh, thanks.
Oh yeah.
I don't big.
Thanks to, uh, Franz Rosen.
Um, anybody who's ever inspired me.
No, this is great though.
Really, um, really high quality, quality thing here.
I'm definitely going to be using that.
And man, it saves us so much time too, because there's so much like encoding that you have to do to really like thoroughly bypass things.
And you just need that one anomaly, you know, you just need that one anomaly to start seeing some, some weird stuff there.
Yep.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
All right.
Um, let's see.
So, okay.
You want to keep the tool chain rolling?
We'll just, we can do that.
You want to go down to, uh, the, the, this one right here.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's talk about this.
Okay.
So this is really interesting because, oh geez.
I mean, this had to have been before COVID even.
I was working with Smeagol's on some like random tool.
And I think there was a tool called like fast.js or something, or like fast.sh.
I think that's what it was called.
It was like a really old tool.
And basically it was just like designed to do like DNS lookups in bulk and like detect good DNS servers and whatever.
I was like, oh, this is like really slow.
Let's, let's make it faster.
And so I wrote this tool called fast.py.
And I think I actually released it, um, on my GitHub.
Let's see.
No.
Fresh.py.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Fresh.py.
So it was a remix of fresh.sh.
Yeah.
Fresh.
Not, not fast.
So fresh.sh basically just fetches a bunch of DNS resolvers, tests them, tries to find a list of good resolvers so that you can do big mass DNS lookups.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, this is slow.
So I wrote fresh.py, which did it way faster.
And then I also have a private version of it, fresh.go.
Um, and, and that was, that was, that was a naming, Joel.
I love that.
Thank you.
And you know, I try to be original.
Uh, uh, yeah.
So I completely forgot about that project.
And then, I don't know, like a month ago, Smeagol's tweets out that the company that, uh, he founded, co-founder of Hadrian, uh, has this new tool called Sanic DNS.
It does, I mean, it definitely blows my tool like way out of the water.
Well, this is also, this does full resolutions as well.
This is like a, right.
It's not just like DNS alternative.
Exactly.
It's not just like clean resolver finding.
It's very like, it's, I mean, like, okay, 5 million lookups per second.
That's insane, man.
I feel like the resolvers, I feel like at 5 million, like resolves per second, you're just gonna, like the resolvers are gonna be like, okay, that guy is actually becoming a problem now.
Like, it's one of those things where like, so I think, uh, the only time I really hit this crux was when I got 10 gig service at my house.
Oh my God, dude.
And here we go again with the 10 gig service.
Here's the thing, when you get an internet that fast, you realize, oh yeah, most things actually aren't designed to like work with networks this fast.
Um, and I think you're probably gonna find a very similar thing with Sanic DNS, which is that like most DNS resolvers and infrastructure is not designed to do 5 million requests per second.
So, uh, that's gonna, that's definitely gonna be something you're gonna have to probably work around a little bit.
Yeah.
Um, but you know, if you really want to see those types of speeds, that being said, even if it works at like a fraction of that, like 1 million DNS requests per second.
Totally crazy.
And I love how the first step, if you go to the, the GitHub repo for this, the first step of getting started is you're gonna need more memory.
So go ahead and, and like allocate yourself another extra gigabyte of memory with like, uh, DP, DK, huge pages.
Um, so that's, that's pretty, that's pretty hilarious.
Also, I love, can I just say, I love the artwork for this?
Like they just got Sonic, like gotta go fast.
And then the Sanic, uh, the Sanic meme.
And so is that, is that meme actually Sanic?
Like, is that what they?
Yeah, that's the Sanic meme.
Okay.
See, I, I was just connected from now.
I thought they were just being silly with Sonic.
Because of their dad and now he's like full boomer.
Yeah.
You know, hey man.
Completely disconnected from internet culture.
From internet memes.
Great.
Thanks for that.
Um, but yeah, dude, this is, um, I think this is, you know, every couple of years we see a core tool that I think is used by, uh, a lot of, a lot of, um, people get, uh, unseated or whatever.
Right.
Somebody, somebody takes the crown.
And I think this one might take it from MassDNS.
Um, I've been, I've used MassDNS for the past, uh, a long time.
Um, and it looks like this might be the move now.
And I actually, I actually passed this off to Donut as well, because, um, you know, Donut's kind of like my go-to guy when I'm talking about high performance tools.
I'm like, cause he knows what's up with that.
Right.
He wrote a really high performance, uh, port scanner and stuff like that.
And he just sort of skimmed the code and took a look at it.
And he said that it seems like they're doing all these things, right?
They're using something that I had never even heard of called XDP sockets, which apparently stands for express data path sockets.
Um, which I guess is just express sockets.
I don't know, like sockets, but faster.
Yeah.
I think it's like basically like kernel level sockets.
Oh yeah.
It's sort of the idea.
I mean, like there's a certain point, right?
Where you start to get capped by user land stuff and you need, you need things to be like lower level, uh, or higher level, I guess, lower level, whatever you want.
Yeah.
Lower level.
To, to, to be, you know, optimally fast.
So like one of the things that's in the, uh, in the read me that talks that it talks about is like, it has this I40E driver support so it can hook directly, it can bind directly onto the Nick.
Like.
Oh, really?
And it works with like 10 gig and up, right?
So it's like 10, 25 and 40 gig, uh, cards.
Oh my gosh.
Like Intel Nick cards.
And then it can do, you know, they said on a 40 gig line, they were able to do seven and a half million requests per second.
Oh my gosh.
That's like, you know, with their own resolver.
Um, but even still like, that's just like ridiculous.
So very, very cool.
I, I feel like this is one of those tools that you develop out of necessity, which, uh, is pretty awesome.
So it just kind of shows you like what sort of like the end game, uh, version of like DNS lookups and stuff looks like when you're like really trying to do it at scale and efficiently.
I wonder, I wonder what AcidNode is doing with, um, with DNS lookups, like whether they're, they're wrapping mass DNS or whether they've got a custom solution.
I was about to say, I've had some really in-depth conversations with the folks over there about how they do stuff.
Uh, I don't think I'm going to say anything specific, but, um, they definitely do some really cool stuff.
And, um, you know, similar to this, you have to push sort of the boundaries of how you're like, you have to really rethink how you do stuff in order to break through, you know, these sort of limit caps.
Yeah. Yeah. I agree. Very cool. So new, normally we, we don't really cover, uh, you know, big recon stuff super much on here, but, um, I think a, a tool unseating mass DNS as the go-to DNS resolver is probably a good one to mention.
So, uh, that's why I bring that up. Okay. So let me go back to what I was saying before, um, which was on the podcast a couple of weeks ago, probably now, um, I talked about the, um, the write-ups from orange from this, uh, this past DEF CON black hat.
And, um, I mentioned that I hadn't, you know, when I went to go reproduce it, I was like, ah, ah, shit, my Apache is actually patched.
And I, I didn't actually even like intentionally patch it. It was, it was just patched already. Um, and so I was like, dang, I don't really feel like spinning up this whole thing or whatever.
And, and so I, I just didn't, didn't continue with the, with the, uh, reproducing of it. Um, but, uh, and then I saw on Twitter that, uh, Hari sec, uh, released a GitHub recall, uh, GitHub recall, GitHub repo, man.
It's, it's the morning, man. I gotta, I gotta take my, sip my coffee. Um, uh, GitHub repo called orange confusion attacks.
And essentially he Dockerized all of these, um, attacks that orange released in that, in that presentation, which is super duper helpful.
So you can play with them and like fine tune your tools if you're trying to get some detection going for it. Um, so we'll drop that link down in the description.
But the, I, I, dude, I just, I so appreciate when people do this sort of thing where they minimize that friction piece to like playing around with something new.
And I would love to see more people integrate that into their research flow.
Um, and say like, Hey, you know, I'm releasing some new research on XYZ.
Here is a Docker container that you can use to reproduce this.
Like, boom, like no problem.
Yeah, that's exactly what I was going to say.
I think like creating a Docker container, I mean, as you're doing research, it's probably not your first thought because I catch myself doing this all the time where I start to overcomplicate things.
And if I were to think about like, Oh, I want to do research on this web server.
Like, let me Dockerize the whole process.
Like before I even like, that's basically definition overcomplicating things.
Yeah.
So I would probably have stopped myself there.
That being said, if you're going to release it, make it easy, you know, for people to do that sort of research and just like go that extra mile and it'll make it so much better.
So that, you know, I love Harisek, I love Orange, but the fact that, you know, one of them had to do the extra mile for the other is, you know.
Yeah, it's great.
You know, and so I think, I think one, if you want to be a member of the community that, that like does something like this and that's like your thing, I think that would be super cool.
I think you would get really popular.
If you just started tweeting out like, Hey, pretty good at generating Docker files.
Exactly.
Here's, here's the research.
Here's the Docker file so you can reproduce it.
I mean, super helpful.
And then, you know, to any of you guys out there that are actually producing like your own security research that that would also, I think is, it would be, would be massive.
And I, dude, I also feel like, I feel like Docker is just kind of like a high value skill for security researchers to just understand, you know, even if you're not doing Docker container security or anything like that.
But like, I think if you just understand how it works and, and are able to spin up Docker containers easily and create Docker containers pretty easily.
I think that that is a very high value skill.
It will save you a lot of time and effort.
Yeah, for sure.
I mean, it's one of those technologies where it's like, it's like, for me, like I would view it almost as like Linux, right?
Or like knowing how to use a shell where it's like, it's, it's sort of one of those fundamental technologies that at minimum you should, you should be like familiar with and understand like the core concepts of, even if you don't like understand it at a super low level, like just knowing like, oh, okay, there's containers and these containers are like templated.
And you can have like commands and this Docker file like sets up like a container and like a specific way that's reproducible.
Like just like knowing like the basics of what Docker is, how to use it, have some, have some experience with it.
Like if you don't have that, take a day, like on the, this weekend.
It's worth it.
I mean, it really is.
Like, you know, take a day out of your weekend, just like sit down for a couple hours, like install Docker, create some basic containers, fiddle around with it, like read through some docs.
It'll be worth your watch.
And I feel like I, like I'm sitting here preaching this, right?
And I've done this multiple times, but I also am not really to the level where I'm like, yeah, you know, I, I, I'm a Docker guy, you know, I can use Docker, you know, like.
But that's fine, right?
Like, yeah, you've hit the minimum.
Like, you know, like it's one of those things where.
I'm not scared of it, but also I'm not like, ah, that's easy, you know?
And I feel like.
But I also think like you don't need to necessarily know, like, you know, it's not, it's not like so mandatory that you should, like everybody should know.
You know, everything about Docker, like if you're doing a project that involves Docker, like a great example, you want to reverse engineer some software and there's a Docker container for it.
Mm hmm.
Most people aren't going to know how to do that, like how to do what, like pull files out of a Docker container.
I only know how to do it because I wanted to do that specifically.
And I looked up how to do it.
And if I wanted to do it again, I would have to look it up again.
Yeah.
So like, it's just one of those things that like, you know, you get familiar with it out of necessity and, you know, what, you know, learn it as you need it.
I feel that, man.
Yeah.
I think, I think for me, I, I, it's not something that I, I use super duper often because I, I'm not doing a lot of this, like, uh, uh, patch reverse engineering or like even really going after enterprise software that often.
But, um, whenever I sit down and I actually, I'm like, Oh, let me just like build a Docker container for this or, you know, how spin up this Docker container.
It's like that.
I'm like, Oh, that was much easier than I expected it to be.
And maybe I shouldn't let these, these, um, you know, inhibitions hold me back in a lot of, in a lot of scenarios.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
So do next one.
Um, actually, I do have, I do have a transition for this one.
You ready for this?
So actually this is super way out there.
Cause I was going to say, you, but you know what a Docker container that I have built is, which is the WordPress testing environment, Docker container.
Um, and, and also related to WordPress.
Cut.
No, no, no, Joe.
We don't do cuts on this podcast, man.
We don't do cuts.
All right.
Um, no.
So I, I did want to shout this, this right up out though, because it's, it's super good.
So, um, the writeup of course that I'm talking about is the, uh, WordPress give WP, uh, pop chain to RCE writeup done by, um, Mr.
Tuxracer.
And when Mr. Tuxracer drops anything specifically WordPress stuff, like he's just quite good with WordPress stuff.
Um, I feel like his tweets have a minimum bar of being like RCE or worse.
I, yeah.
Yeah.
Like, like RCE or global, universal RCE.
Um, yeah.
So I, I think this is a really good writeup.
I think he did, he does a good job of, I mean, clearly he went in there and like, you know, reproduced it thoroughly himself.
And I love the little details that he added in here.
So for example, let me, let me read you this.
Um, he's talking about the, the situation or the specific, um, location where, uh, the deserialization is happening, um, in this chain.
And he says, uh, PHP object injection exploits usually reference class names using their namespaces, which might contain slashes.
Strip slashes underscore deep tries to get rid of these by calling strip slashes on every value.
However, this can be easily bypassed by using four backslashes, um, in the namespace names.
And I just like this, this sort of detail might be something that a lot of writeup people would just sort of solve themselves and then skip over and not include, you know, in the actual writeup itself.
But I, I find stuff like this extremely useful and also kind of counterintuitive.
Like why does strip slashes allow a backslash in the actual final result?
Like that shouldn't be how that works.
And so I literally sat down and I was like, all right, I got to play with this.
So I, I, I spun up a little PHP thing and I was playing with it.
And essentially, I think the reason why it works is because, um, it will, it will escape.
You know, if you have four backslashes, right, it will convert the two backslashes.
It'll remove one of the backslashes, right?
Cause one of them is an escape character and one of them is a, is a backslash.
It'll remove that.
So it's just a backslash and then it'll do the same one for the next one.
And now you've got two backslashes right next to each other, which is an escaped backslash again.
So it produces a backslash.
Um, and it's just not something that I would have really like intuitively tried to, uh, in this situation.
So it's just great to be aware of the fact that those, that strip slashes can be bypassed in PHP.
Yeah.
So dude, this is one of those like mental gadgets, right?
It's, it's like the little nugget that you get from reading this.
It's like you read through this cool research.
Does it apply?
How many times are you going to see give WP?
Probably not that often.
How many times are you going to see an outdated give WP?
Almost never.
However, that's not really the important part, right?
The important part is how does this work?
Like understanding that.
And then separately the little nuggets, like the strip slashes and how that works.
Because the next time you see something, you know, maybe, you know, it's PHP.
Maybe you don't know it's PHP.
Maybe you do some fingerprinting and find out it's PHP.
Now you have something to add into your payload specifically targeted towards PHP because maybe
they're using strip slashes and you can exploit it in this way.
So it's just, you know, those little, those little mental gadgets.
Yeah.
You know, you don't even have to remember it specifically.
You just, you're like, oh man, what was that?
But your brain will, it'll, it'll, it'll notice it, right?
You see strip slashes and you'll start staring at it.
And you're like, why am I staring at strip slashes?
Like, why do I feel like there's something weird about that?
And then you'll, you'll look it up.
Start searching like strip slashes, bug bounty RCE.
Yeah, exactly.
RCE, RCE will get you there.
Yeah, no, that's great, man.
A couple other takeaways that I had for this one was the entry point for this attack.
And we talked about this a little bit way back in episode, I don't know, whatever number
it was where we, we started.
We talked about WordPress security a lot, but one of the main ways to do WordPress security
in a lot of the, the API flows is to have these nonces in place.
And sometimes these nonces will only be accessible from pages where admins can access or something
like that.
Right.
But technically the end point where you utilize the nonce doesn't actually require that privilege.
You, anybody can hit that end point, but if you don't have the nonce, it's going to freak
out.
Right.
So it's like,
I was reading through this.
I was like, oh man, the stars just keep, another one just aligns.
Yeah, no, it's beautiful.
And, and, but I think that's a really good call out for anybody who is looking at WordPress
stuff is like, if you have the, you know, where they're doing the ad action and it's
WP underscore Ajax, right?
That can be triggered by, you know, even a subscriber level user.
Right.
And if there's not a, an actual permission check on that, there's just a nonce verification
check, then you may be able to leak that nonce.
And actually call that function still.
And, you know, even more so if it's like WP Ajax, no priv, and you can just hit it from
an unauthenticated perspective or like admin init or something like that.
So I, and I've, I've got some, we've got some automation actually set up in the, in the
critical thinkers channel for the data streams section where we automatically scan every
new, new commit done to WordPress plugins above 50,000 installs.
And we use a, AST tree to go through, wait, AST tree.
Yeah.
The tree tree.
The tree tree to go through and like, look for these verification nonces and, um, lack of,
uh, ways for checking various credit or, um, roles within the WordPress APIs.
Um, so we catch a lot of those bugs when those come through.
I think that that script probably pops out a couple CVs a month, at least, um, uh, that
just get handed off to the critical thinkers community and, and, uh, they make a couple
bucks on it here and there.
But I think this sort of situation where you have a nonce and the nonces in place, but the
nonce is actually leakable is a, is a more complicated situation that, um, would be a
little bit more if you're doing intentional research on a plugin.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And on top of that, yesterday I got an email.
I'll give a little free shout out here.
Okay.
From the word fence folks.
All right.
Um, who are now running a couple different, um, bug bounty promotions on their thing.
They've ink, they've added XSS vulnerabilities on anything over a thousand plus installs into
scope.
They have increased bounties.
They have a new install tier for plugins with over 5 million active installs, um, with
bounties up to 30 K.
So, I mean, we have alerts for plugins.
There's some new research on plugins.
There's some higher bounties for plugins.
So maybe, uh, maybe this weekend, if you want to go check out, uh, some of the WordPress
plugins and go get some 30 K bounties.
Wow.
30 K is a serious bounty dude.
Yeah.
That's a, that's legit legit.
So very, very cool stuff.
Um, and, uh, you know, I don't think WordPress is going anywhere anytime soon.
It's used everywhere, man.
It's everywhere.
It is really a high value thing to know the ins and outs of.
So the weird thing is like, it'll be used on like sites that you would never expect to
be WordPress.
Like, you'll just run recon and like my nuclei will say, Hey, by the way, this is running
WordPress.
I'm like, heck, this is running WordPress.
And then I'd run a WP scan and, uh, you know, Oh, it's got like all these different plugins.
So definitely, uh, definitely not going anywhere.
Yeah.
I'm going to look up the episode really quick.
Um, yeah.
Popping WordPress plugins methodology brain dump.
Uh, episode 55 is the one where we, we are joined by that, uh, word fence researcher.
And we kind of talk about what the approach is to hack WordPress bugs or, uh, find, find
WordPress vulnerabilities because, you know, at the end of the day, it's PHP, right?
So of course, you know, if somebody is just putting a PHP file out there and they're just
like, you know, echoing dollar sign underscore get whatever, then you're going to, you're
going to get XSS.
But, um, there's also a lot of custom PHP, uh, WordPress synergies that happen.
The only thing I'll say is, okay.
The only times I've ever used PHP ever is in the most hacky of situations.
Okay.
It's like, I never write a PHP POC when I'm like, ha, I just, I just need something normal.
It's like when I need some really weird, like I need to add a header in the response in real
time.
I know like, so that's a, you probably, I'm running an eval and like the head, like,
dude, actually, have you seen the whole, and we won't, we won't rabbit trail down this for
too long, but have you seen the like movement lately surrounding, like reverting to PHP
and jQuery and just shipping really fast for like, let's go.
I'm so here for it.
The levels IO, like, I know you said we weren't going to rabbit hole on this, but I, a week
or two ago, I was just like, just for fun.
I went down the, the cursor rabbit hole, uh, like AI code writing and projects and stuff.
And, uh, I literally got to the point where I was like, okay, I don't want any react.
I want basic HTML.
I want this to look like nineties website, like straight HTML, JavaScript.
And it, it actually worked way better.
Dude, it's, it's, it's a real thing, man.
I think, uh, I think there's something to be said about just taking the minimum required,
you know, technology to do it.
Okay.
All right, Joel, I'm, I'm writing us back in.
Last, last comment that I want to, I want to have on this one is if you're not familiar
with pop chains, I think that's a pretty cool loan class to at least understand if you,
if you like to geek out over stuff.
Um, and it's, it's a deserialization, you know, uh, technique, uh, but man, those things
are fun to research.
And when, when we were going down the, uh, the WordPress rabbit hole back earlier this
year, um, it's just, I had so much fun hunting for pop chain gadgets, uh, to allow, allow to
pivot from class to class and actually get arbitrary code execution.
Um, and this example here in the, um, in the, uh, blog post by, by Mr. Tuxracer is, is
pretty awesome.
I think he, he pulled this graphic from the, yeah, he did.
He pulled it from the word fence teams blog.
Um, but I, I appreciate when they break down all that and allow us to see the beauty of
what a pop chain looks like in its full glory.
Cause like, this is what it's five steps before it even gets to the code execution.
So you're, you're in deep, deep by the time you actually pop something.
Yeah, very much so.
I mean, it's one of those scenarios where you're like, is this actually kind of pop?
And when it does, oh man, it feels so good.
Feels, feels so good, dude.
All right.
Awesome.
Where do you want to go?
Another tool?
All right.
It's tool Tuesday.
Uh, okay.
It really is.
Joel.
Hey man.
Hey, thank you for evening, evening the score because I, I did a crappy transition earlier.
So, um, all right.
Tool Tuesday.
All right.
You're done talking now.
No, no, no.
Wait, that was the best transition of all time.
Go, go.
All right.
So yes, we hack.
Yes, we hack.
Has released a tool called XSS tools.
This has been around for a while.
Just FYI.
They released it three years ago.
Um, yeah, no, it's crazy.
I have literally never heard of this thing.
You linked this, uh, up until, uh, five seconds ago.
I thought this was brand new.
Brand new release.
Um, I linked it to one of my friends.
He was like, what?
This is cool.
So it, this is awesome.
Um, so the, the, the, the best way I can, uh, analogize this.
Analogize.
I can make an analogy for this is this is a terrible analogy.
Oh my God.
Anybody.
I'm sorry.
This is maybe the worst way I can make an analogy for it.
Anybody who's used pwn tools before, uh, for like native, native exploitation, binary exploitation.
Um, yeah, so pwn tools is like this Python library that you can import and you just do like from pwn import star.
And then you just have all these functions that are like awesome, like helper functions.
You can like decode stuff.
This is actually pretty rad, dude.
Break points, whatever.
So this like, it's kind of like that, but for XSS.
So it's like this library, you just import this dot JS file, and then it gives you all these functions that you can call.
So you, you know, you just do like payload dot new, then you do dot add exfiltrator and you give it a function to exfiltrate and you do dot eval.
And then it's like run some code and you dot exfiltrate and it exfiltrates it to your exfiltrator and it dot fetch dom.
And it like gets a page from the right.
So it does like all these, like, it's just a lot of helper functions that like, if you were to write an XSS, uh, payload, like you were, you're, you have an XSS, you want to exploit it and like build out a POC.
Building out the POC is big pit.
Yeah.
Big pit.
Jeez.
It is a big pain, dude.
Much like your throat is experiencing right now.
But, um, but yeah, no, no, no, no.
It's really awesome.
The exfiltrators piece I think is really, is really cool too, right?
Because listen to this.
There's, listen to these exfiltrators.
Uh, post message exfiltration, get based exfiltration, uh, send beacon based exfiltration, image exfiltration, iframe exfiltration.
So like it's, it's got a bunch of scenarios for ways when you have limited exfiltration methodologies and you don't have to like go and write all this custom code for it.
You just import the library and boom, boom, boom.
So yeah, dude, um, bit K dropped this on me when he was doing the, um, the, the prototype pollution masterclass in the, in the critical thinkers discord.
And, uh, I was like, wow, how have I not heard of this?
Because I feel like this would save a bunch of time, but, but, but also let me just say this kind of gets like this.
I think this was way cooler before AI because now I can just, I literally just go to chat GPT or whatever.
And I'm like, all right, write this to do this.
And then it just does it.
And it works so well.
Um, the one thing I will say though, I think there are probably some areas where you can improve this a little bit because like chat GPT is good for like basic stuff.
Um, when it gets like more complicated, a little, it can, maybe it's okay sometimes.
Um, but like when you're talking about exfiltrators, I'm thinking, okay, let's add the port swigger CSS blind exfiltration technique.
Yeah.
As an exfiltrator and let's like update this.
Cause this is, you know, three years out of date now.
So there's probably some other exfiltration methods that have come up since then.
That's the person that came to mind.
And, uh, then, you know, in those really weird scenarios, I think this still has a really good use case where you want to write a really high quality POC that just works and you can just do this.
Yeah.
It just works.
So dude, but also check this out.
Like there's, there's a, a payload here within here that says start key logger.
Like that's the kind of stuff that I, that, that it's nice to have like modulized.
Right.
Cause it's like, ah, I know it's possible in the read me.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
I know that it's, it's, it's possible for me to like do a key logger, but then I got to like write all the JavaScript and like, you know, exfiltrate it out.
But this thing will just automatically do it.
So, um, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Also, I'm sorry, Joel.
The other thing that I was really excited about, which is kind of ironic cause it's click jacking.
But, um, is the, is the click jacking functionality here.
Okay.
So listen, listen up critical, critical thinking listeners here.
Um, I'm not warranting, I'm not saying that click jacking is a valid bug.
You heard it here first.
Most of the situations.
At the bottom of your reports.
Ryan Erader told me that click jacking is a valid report.
Joel, please stop.
Bounty, please.
No.
Um, but there are scenarios.
I have had a click jacking accepted as a high.
When you have, uh, like a click jacking on, for example, on an OAuth approval page, so where
you can just force the button, you know, they click one button and now their account is pwned,
right?
Valid.
The thing is, these things are a pain in the ass to write because you've got to like align
all the things and where's the button?
Who knows?
You know, it's a whole, it's a whole step.
But this, uh, this, this library has a click jacker, um, functionality and all you have
to do writing.
I'm just going to read from the read me here.
Writing click jacking code can be tedious with excess tools.
You only need to supply the position of the target element on the, on the, on the target
page.
And then you're good to go.
And I'm just like, ah, yes, this is what I need.
This is what I need.
It's so good.
I mean, this is, this is awesome.
Um, I, I love little helper tools like this.
Um, and okay, bad transition.
Number two, are you ready?
Are you done with this one?
No, no, no, I'm not done.
Okay.
Finish.
Let me just say, let me, let me add one more thing about the click checker.
Okay.
Um, not only did they, did they build that into it?
Right.
But they also gave us this little one liner down at the bottom that says, Hey, you can
find the, the bounding box interactively using this code.
So they just give you like a JavaScript one liner that you can just toss into your, into your
script console.
It's these little, little snippets, man.
It's, it's clutch.
It's the little nuggets.
It's so clutch.
So, um, yeah, I'm sorry.
That's all I wanted to say.
It just really helpful for, uh, uh, XSS exfiltration and, um, in click jacking POCs.
So, okay.
Take it away.
Go ahead.
Well, the impact is, is right here.
You know, it's, they give you the impact in the read me and you know, what else reminds
me of impact somebody in our discord in the hacking channel.
Oh my God, Joel.
That violent.
Okay.
This guy, this was nuts.
This was actually crazy.
I'm not going to lie.
Like normally I'm like, uh, skeptical of injection, text injection, HTML injection, whatever.
Okay.
This is pretty big brain.
I will not lie.
Uh, this guy found, uh, I guess it's just HTML injection, right?
Dude, I don't, dude, it's actually not even HTML injection.
This is text injection, Joel.
This is just text injection.
This is not even HTML.
There is not a bug here.
Right.
It's like bug question mark.
Uh, so what they did is they realized, hang on a second.
You ever seen those ASCII art, those, those big, like the man's dancing in the chat, you
know, on like Twitch chat and it's all ASCII art.
Yeah.
So he was like, hang on a second, big brain moment.
And then he built a QR code out of these ASCII Unicode, uh, block characters, whatever,
like solid, like the solid white squares.
And then like the like shaded square characters or whatever.
Uh, I don't know how to describe this without a screenshot.
Um, but yeah, they basically, they built a QR code.
Yeah.
We'll put it up.
All right.
I just can put it up.
But there's a screenshot in our discord from this guy in the hacking channel.
Um, and, uh, it's just text injection, but it's, it builds out a QR code and I don't
know.
You scan the, so Joel, I talked to him.
You scan the QR code and it takes over your account.
Right.
And so it's like, this is amazing, dude.
Like this is, I will say, I will say, I will say he went through a lot of effort here, uh,
to redact the URL and, and like all of the surrounding stuff, the surrounding stuff.
And then the rock, you are, Oh, the rock QR codes there.
Okay.
Shit.
Maybe we can't put it up on the screen.
Dang it.
I will say, uh, you probably could just opening Chrome.
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to take me to a thing.
I'm trying to hello from, I'm going to guess.
That's probably the target.
Dude, dude, don't say it on air.
Now we got to bleep.
I didn't say it.
I just said hello from blank.
Okay.
So maybe we, yeah.
So I don't know.
Maybe we'll put it up on the screen.
Maybe we won't.
But what I wanted to bring to you.
I'll leave that as an exercise.
Okay, Joel, just you take a second.
Cause I think you're crying over there right now.
This is such a beautiful exploit.
I just wanted to bring this, bring this, um, to the, to the listeners because dude, isn't
this such a beautiful representation of hacker mentality, right?
Like, like text injection, classic NA bug, right?
It doesn't matter at all, but this guy figures out a way to use some technical prowess to use
his knowledge of, of Unicode.
And I think he also had like some sort of tangential CSS injection on this page that allowed him
to do some like CSS, uh, realigning or whatever.
Um, but to make this QR code, and then he uses his knowledge of the app to take that, when
that QR code actually gets scanned, it, it, it does something, you know, bad to their,
to their account.
So I, presumably they're using like a same site strict or something like that, which is
why it needs to originate from, um, well, no, I, I'm not, I'm not sure that should just
be a C-serve.
So maybe it's just a part of the, the attack methodology, but he went the, the full, the
full way to build out this whole POC.
And when you do that, man, doesn't your heart just like swell with pride?
Like what it's well, Luth is I hope triage didn't just go, we're having trouble reproducing
this bug.
Like, because like, this is one of those things where I think when, like, if you can get it
to the team, it's like a beautiful side of bug bounty that is so creative.
Yeah.
And so like out of the box thinking that it's so cool where it's like, you have like chat
GPT couldn't come up with that shit in a million years.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like straight up, you could feed that problem.
You could click the regenerate button a thousand times.
It'll never be like, you should generate a QR code with ASCII characters with your text
injection, right?
Like that is, it's such a cool, like unique, um, attack scenario.
And it's so creative.
Like if I had received that, I'd be like, all right, at minimum low bounty just for creativity.
Well, dude, like, I think it also just kind of pays for itself a little bit too,
you know, not to say that, that you don't need to pay for these super crazy bugs.
Cause I think the company should, but like when you get to the end of that, that I just
finished a POC last night for a bug that I am super proud of.
That's like, uh, like, you know, it's, it's funny.
I call it like a matan bear bug now after that episode, cause it's like, and then I, you
do this and I grabbed this cookie and then overflow the cookie jade like this and that, and the
other thing.
And you, it comes together and it's so smooth and clean and you just, it feels so good.
You know?
Um, and then the next morning triage goes, Hey, do you own this domain?
Yeah, exactly.
Lovely.
Yeah.
Well, it's ups and downs of bug bounty, man.
That's something that's never happened to me before.
Let me just, thank you for that job.
Um, but yeah, I think, uh, shout out to Valant here from the, from the discord.
This is a very cool, uh, strategy of text injection and Unicode characters to build out
a QR code.
Um, very cool.
Very cool.
Indeed.
All right.
Let's, let's see what else we got on the list for today, dude.
Um, okay.
Let, let, let's jump back up to this, uh, uh, browser tracking protection thing.
Okay.
So I'm gonna let you take this.
Yeah.
I got, I got you.
This was dense AF.
Yes, it was.
It was very dense.
I didn't even know this was a thing by the way.
And it took me a very.
Like more Google searches than it should have to even find out what this IT thing is.
I was like, what is ITP?
And it was like, ITP is a mechanism for, I was like, no, no, no.
What is it?
Yeah.
What does ITP stand for?
Yeah, exactly.
And, and, and so essentially what this article is, and we'll link it down below.
It's, um, it's bypassing browser tracking prevention or protection for cores, uh, misconfiguration
abuse by, um, the PT security team.
Um, and essentially what this blog post does is it details, um, Safari's and Firefox's
answer of sorts to Chrome's same site lacks.
Okay.
So what they've done in Firefox and, uh, Safari is they've implemented these, uh, tracking
protections that happened by, by default, um, which prevent cookies from being sent to
third-party domains so that you're not getting tracked by like, oh, you came to this website
and there was like a pixel for whatever, and it set a cookie and now we know who you are
forever.
Right.
Um, uh, and, and, and these have been kind of foiling, um, exploits for a little while.
Like I've been, I've heard some murmurs in the critical thinking, um, discord and, and
in the community, a little bit of like, man, this exploit works fine here, but it doesn't
work over here.
Like, why is that happening?
Um, and it's because Firefox and, and Safari have implemented these.
So, um, the TLDR of the situation is that, uh, you, you won't be able to send not top level,
um, requests.
So like a fetch request or whatever with, with credentials with it in Safari or Firefox, if
you don't first do a window dot open to the, the vulnerable page.
Okay.
And so what this means is that if you do see a vulnerable cores configurations nowadays,
typically I've been kind of not paying attention to those very much because, uh, same site kind
of screws with that.
If it's cookie based authentication, which it has to be for, for that.
Um, but this is still very possible in, in Firefox and in Safari, because, um, you just
need to harvest one click to open up a window.
And when you do that, uh, at least in Firefox is the case, um, there's a relationship between
those two domains stored for 30 days.
So let's say I do it from, you know, my poc.rineradio.com to google.com.
I do a window.open, right?
So, so now poc.rineradio.com can send credentialed requests to google.com for 30 days.
Okay.
And, um, and so all you got to do is do that window.open and then you're good to go.
Uh, I think Safari, you have to wait like two seconds or something like that because
of something janky.
Um, yeah, it's kind of weird.
You got to use like a set timeout or whatever before you can send the request.
But, um, but the, this, this attack still absolutely works.
And the majority of this blog post was just explaining the setup and explaining what this
thing is and the way that they went about, you know, building a test environment for it,
which is cool and helpful if you want to play around with it a little bit more.
But I was a little bit over underwhelmed when I got to the end and I'm just like, oh, it's
just like window.open.
Okay, cool.
You know, like I'll do that.
That's a real, that's really, really interesting.
It kind of reminds me.
So, uh, I don't know.
I don't think I added, I added this and then I removed it because I knew you wouldn't have
time to read it, but I don't know if you, if you saw, there was this CTF writeup from
IDK CTF 2024.
Um, and this is the iframe thing.
Yeah.
Dude, I read it.
Dude, my mentee sent it to me as soon as it, like three days ago.
Yeah.
And, and I, I woke up and I like looked at, looked at the message.
I was like, oh, what's this?
I clicked on it and it was like 6am in the morning.
I was reading it groggy and I'm like, oh my gosh, this is insane.
I can't even process any of this.
It's insane.
But like, uh, you know, there's a lot of this like sort of similar behavior where like,
if you like load a page first, then it like allow, it sets like different CSP behavior
or like, uh, sorry, not CSP.
Um, yeah.
Cross origin or CSP or sandboxing behavior.
Right.
It inherits the CSP and then it like, yeah, uh, I also need to reread because it was so
that dude, I read through it.
I was like, what the heck?
Like there was like new, uh, attributes that I didn't even know, like iframe sandbox and
iframe, um, source doc.
Yeah.
Now we're going to have to find that link and put it in the description.
I put it at the bottom.
Oh, did you?
Okay.
But yeah, well, maybe we'll save that for next week.
Yeah.
Maybe we will, because I actually would like to go back and, and reread that and get a
more concrete grip on it because that iframe stuff and the, uh, attribute inheritance and
like all of that is really, um, is really tricky.
Um, but yeah, I, I just want to swing back around to this, uh, this browser tracking protection
thing for a second, because I feel like this is one of those issues that kind of like slid
under the radar and has been kind of foiling POCs, uh, uh, you know, and you're like, why
is this working?
I know that this should work.
Um, this is, this is very well could be the reason if you're in Firefox or Safari.
So, um, just do a window.open to your target page anytime within the past 30 days from that
origin and you're, you're good to go.
Um, all right.
Oh, here's the other dude.
I had another one, one more interesting takeaway from this.
Um, this setting is not a, I was kind of curious about how the setting gets stored, right?
Let me, let me take a sip of something real quick.
Cause I, I, my throat is hecking up.
Okay.
Um, this is not stored.
I was kind of wondering how this was stored.
Right.
And so I was like, oh, I wonder if this could actually tell us whether we have been on a
specific website or not within the past, um, however many days by detecting whether we could
send a cross origin request to that website.
Right.
Um, and, and it turns out you can, and even if you go and you clear your browser history, if
you go to that, that website and you send a, uh, a request and it sends cookies, that setting
is still there.
Um, okay.
Um, hear me out.
Hear me out.
Yeah.
There's a canary there.
I don't know if you realized it, but in the same way that you can like CSS exfiltrate
with like, you know, like the sort of like true, like if it goes through, then that's an indicator.
So, you know, you could brute force, like, you know,
cross site leak of sorts, right?
Right.
Yeah.
Like, you know, if, if the request goes through, then you know, that path exists.
So you brute force paths until you hit one that exists.
And yeah, I mean, you, you, but here's the thing you have to control, right?
You have to control JavaScript execution on the website in of that target.
Oh, so if they clicked on the link, then you should already be able to know that.
Um, but yeah, it's, it's, it's more, it's more interesting from like a just general
overall security perspective where it's like, okay, well, I cleared my browser history, but also
this, uh, you know, if I go to, you know, whatever website and say fetch has, has the
user clicked on a link from this website and gone to another website.
And yes, that setting is still stored.
Um, so I just thought that was an interesting little tidbit.
Uh, I don't think it's a actionable vulnerability or anything, but, um, there definitely is some
interesting, um, nuance to it because you, you can, if you do get an XSS, you could even
trigger this attack from the client side.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, and if this, if it does go through, then you have a, a true or false on whether the
user has logged into a specific, you know, or clicked on a link from this website to a different
website, um, in the, in the past 30 days, which is, gives you a decent amount of, of time
range on it.
Um, so yeah.
I don't know, man, a little, a little bit, a little bit weird, a little bit fringe, but
I figured, uh, I figured I'd mention it just cause, uh, generally security related.
Okay.
Um, let me see.
Yeah.
This next one.
All right.
Um, I'll, I'll, I'll take the Dom clobbering one as well, if you don't mind, cause I
have been playing around with this lately.
Sure.
I saw this still and I was like, uh, again, it's tool Tuesday, man.
Yeah.
Tool Tuesday.
Well, so essentially how this conversation started is I think somebody in the critical thinkers
here was asking about Dom clobbering.
I think it was like a XSS doctor or something.
And then Jay had X hopped up in there and dropped this research on us.
And, uh, and we're like, Whoa, what is, what is this?
And, uh, there's some really great research.
I mean, I think this has been around, uh, this was 2023.
So it's actually a pretty recent research, um, from somebody named.
So hail code.
Diary.
Sorry about that.
I did my best.
Um, but it's, it's, it's everything, um, everything you wanted to know about Dom clobbering,
but we're afraid to ask.
And I think this is a really cool, um, presentation for anybody who wants to like, understand Dom clobbering
at a basic level and understand how to start exploiting it.
Um, and there's lots of great information in there, but the real gem that came out of that
was this Dom clob dot XYZ website that documents a bunch of like Dom clobbering, um, functionality
that you can use, uh, to essentially clobber certain variables, um, in inside of a Dom when
you only have like HTML injection versus, uh, XSS.
Right.
Um, and within that there is this payload generator.
Once again, of the week of the payload generator, um, where you can bookmarks to add, man.
Yeah.
Where you can say like, okay, the variable I want to clobber is like, um, response dot,
uh, status underscore code.
Right.
And then you just click, click generate and it will generate like five different ways for
you to clobber that variable using an a tag, using a form, uh, using like a text area inside
of a form in all of these things.
Um, and I just think once again, that makes our life much simpler because we know that
that that's possible, but now we got to go and research.
Oh, where's, you know, what elements should I use?
Is it ideas and name?
You know, that's one of the things that is kind of tricky about Dom clobbering.
So this payload generator makes it much easier.
Yeah, dude.
You know, I, I love, I think the way I love to think about this is like, um, like a contractor
who has like those, like a really expensive tool, right?
Like a, like a really, like it was an investment, but like it does something very specific, very
well.
And you're like, why do you have that?
And it's like, because if I didn't have that, I would have to know how to do it the
other way or manually or the old school way.
And instead I have invested in this tool to do it better.
Yeah.
And that is exactly what this type of stuff is.
Like, could you go through and like, you know, maybe there's something to be said about like
the learning process of like, maybe you do that once, like the first time you do a Dom
clobbering just to understand like how it works and get all the background or whatever,
but then like use the tool, like make your life easier and like do it more efficiently
because that's why it exists.
Like having tools and using them effectively is like so, so important.
Yeah.
Especially for career hunters, right?
Like if you're going to be in, you know, security for the rest of your life, like I plan to be,
like it makes sense to invest in these tools and build them out and know about them and
document them for yourself.
Because sometimes there are people out there whose thing is Dom clobbering and they're
like going to maintain this website on Dom clobbering for you.
And you just have to know where it is and how to use it.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
So that was, that was, that was a great takeaway.
I definitely have been, I've been thinking about that a lot.
Okay.
So we got a couple more things to go through here, but I kind of want to take a pause real
quick and just reflect on that episode that we did with Franz, like back in, in Vegas.
Okay.
Where he was talking about the, the X correlation IDs and the requests IDs and what kind of logging
pipelines those get integrated into.
Um, and here's why I wanted to pause about that because I'm, I was thinking like, okay,
so Franz found that thing.
That's really cool.
How can we take that, that concept that he, he used and expand it and apply it to other
areas?
Like what are the things like request ID that I was totally sleeping on?
Right.
And, and I, I definitely should have been sussing, but I just was like, ah, it's just request
ID.
Like that never does anything.
Right.
Um, and so I started brainstorming on it a little bit.
I'll give you some time to think Joel, cause I'm kind of throwing this on you last minute.
But, um, one of the things that popped up in my mind is, is, um, is century and or like
client side error logging, um, uh, that, that occurs, um, you know, by a century or by some
other provider.
Right.
And I know that there are some exploits out there.
Like there's like a century SSRF I think hacker one was vulnerable to at one point.
Um, and that sort of thing.
But I feel like that environment in general, um, unless it's all going back to one dashboard
could have a similar, uh, effect to what Franz did with the request ID, right?
Where you, you throw some payloads in there and then that goes through the logging pipeline,
like ends up in like some custom dashboard they've built to like show all of their JS errors
or whatever, and then pops and you get access to a bunch of like logged session
tokens or something like that from the client side.
Um, so yeah, that, that, that's one of the things I was thinking of.
Do you have anything in your brain that kind of like, you definitely looked at and thought,
oh, that's sketchy, but I see it everywhere.
No one's exploiting it.
So I'm just going to move along.
Yeah.
I mean, there are definitely things where I sort of draw the line.
So like, I think I used to be a lot more like permissive, I think in terms of like things
I would consider as like, Ooh, maybe there's a bug here.
And like, I think where I really have lately drawn the line is like anything to do with
um, well, yeah.
I mean, most things to do with like new account creation, new setup, like initial setup, account
setup, like that kind of stuff.
Like maybe I'll put some payloads in there, but I'm not super concerned about like recording
the traffic of like a new account setup because maybe there is a bug in there.
Like maybe there's some form of an ATO or something, but like most of the time, like this is a one
time scenario that like happens where like you have very limited amount of configuration.
It like probably won't ever pop up more than once.
So if it's something specific that like a user needs to like hit a certain URL during
the setup phase or something like that's a very hard attack scenario to propose to the
program.
It is.
That being said, like, I'm still going to record it.
I'm still going to look like, you know, but.
Well, I think, I think you can get caught up on that sometimes too.
Like I, I've often spent many times or a lot of time before the many times, man, I don't
know what is wrong with me today, man.
Um, you know, I've spent a lot of time, um, pre pre off, just kind of playing with that
flow and like trying to get it to, to do something funky or whatever.
And I'm like, man, 99.9% of the functionality of this application is on the other side of
this process.
Like maybe I should just, you know, but I also thought you were going to go in a different
direction with that because I've seen a lot of people, um, pop crazy stuff on signup flows
or like, um, one I think under discussed type of bug is, uh, signup hijacking.
If there is some way for you to predict what kind of unique identifier the user will get
before they actually have an account and then, and then brute force that to, to take over
active signups, then I think that that is a really high value attack because then you
can, you can, um, you know, sometimes you can get access to PII that's, uh, cached in
the signup flow or, um, maybe even affect that user's password, whatever.
Um, or maybe even just automatically get logged into their account.
If you just play like, yeah, I accept the terms and conditions and that's like the last
step.
And then it says, okay, welcome to the website or whatever.
Right.
Um, so yeah, I think, I think there's, I think this is kind of like what we talk about when
we say, everybody's got their own set of eyes for, for testing, right?
You know, Franz looks at their quest ID and says, Hmm, I think that could be weird.
And, you know, there's people that look at the signup flow and be like, that seems a little
odd.
And then the rest of us sort of skip over it.
And that's why it's important to have a variety of hackers hacking on your, on your,
on your program, um, rather than just like one pen test company you use every year,
year over year.
Yep.
For sure.
Yeah.
Um, the, did you have any other, anything else you wanted to add to that?
Um, things that are like X correlation ID that you think might be sketchy, but you haven't
taken the time to dive into.
No, but I think like, just generally speaking, like it's a very healthy mindset to like not
get so like systematic about it all.
Yeah.
Like repetitive, like autopilot, right?
Like you don't want to just be like, Oh, I've seen that header a million times.
Like taking a step back and thinking, what is that header?
Like how I ever thoroughly looked into that and, and seen like, what, what, like, why
did they send that header?
Like there's some reason it's not just there for no reason.
Like some technology is sending it or some, some, you know, tracing behind the scenes or
like, you know, it's there for some reason.
Like they don't, you don't put something in an application for no reason.
Yeah.
And I think, um, this is another reason that I really advocate for spending a lot of time
on an application, you know, spending more time than you are, you know, comfortable spending
because you get to the point when you're out of ideas and then you sit there and you're
forced to be creative.
You're supposed to, you're, you're forced to think, all right, well, what if there was
a, you know, RC in the request ID, you know, header, right.
Or like that sort of thing.
And you try those things out and you grow as a hacker.
Um, yeah.
So spend time, spend time, go deep guys.
Um, the last thing that I wanted to mention on that was, um, I think those endpoints that
return a one pixel GIF, I think are mostly just kind of used for logging or like, um,
yeah, the tracking, yeah, tracking pixels and stuff like that.
Um, those don't necessarily, yeah, I've never seen anything weird with those, but I do wonder
where all that data ends up.
And, and what kind of owns there could be there.
So just a couple, couple thoughts that I had surrounding all that.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Uh, okay.
Last thing.
Second, last thing you posted this link and I was very confused because it does nothing
for me.
So maybe you can.
Yeah.
The, the, uh, the one to my website.
Yes.
Okay.
Well, hold up.
Did you, oh shoot.
Oh wait, now it, oh, now it even does even less of something.
Actually, it wasn't doing that before.
Well, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It works.
Yeah.
Click, click, click at the beginning of the link.
Don't click on the middle part.
So, um, this is just a, here, I'll send it to you in discord.
Um, this is just a, a little, uh, quirk of, of HTML that I found out the other day that,
you know, I want to say I mentioned it on the pod, but maybe I didn't.
So I just wanted to go ahead and mention it.
Um, which is that you can, if you have, um, a tag injection, you can actually trigger a
post request, which is something that I didn't know.
So, wait, it still doesn't do anything for you.
I'm clicking it and I'm looking at my network tab and there's nothing.
Um, what?
No, no, no.
It works, dude.
You're, you're tripping.
I'm on the latest Chrome.
You're tripping, dude.
It works.
Um, so, so essentially, let me, let me just tell the people about this and we'll troubleshoot
your janky Chrome instance afterwards.
Um, uh, so essentially if you have an, a, an a tag, which I feel like is one of the more
common places where you can get an injection because a tags are allowed in Markdown.
Um, and sometimes you want to try to trigger a post with that because, um, you, you want
to trigger like a, a C surf on the website and it's like, uh, maybe it's origin based or,
uh, checks for C surf or something like that.
Um, and if you are able to smuggle in the ping attribute, um,
then when you click that, the, the link, it will execute the link, but also will send
a post request to wherever you set the ping attribute to.
Um, and in the post request, I don't know why you can't see it, dude.
I don't know why, but it contains some interesting things.
It contains a header ping from and ping to that contains the full location.
H ref of the page that you're on.
So are you on Firefox?
No, no, no, no.
I'm on Chrome.
Joel.
That's so weird.
You've got some filter on for sure.
Something like that.
You think I'll open it in incognito.
Yeah.
Just try that.
Um, but the ping attribute I thought was really interesting because I didn't know that you
could trigger that post request specifically with an a tag.
Um, and I think this could be helpful for one leaking location, h ref via these, um, these
ping from ping to headers.
And then, um, for two, I think this could be applicable in sort of like a client side path
to a, um, uh, um, text injection or HTML injection to see surf environment, right?
Where you can sort of create this a tag dynamically.
And when the user clicks on it, you trigger some sea surf that happens on the website.
And I think this would also be really helpful in an environment where, um, there are same
site, strict cookies, where the request must originate from the, the same origin for the
cookies to be sent.
Um, so if you can get an a tag injection and add the ping attribute, then you can trigger
that, that poster vest.
Joel, do you still not have it, man?
I'm going to send you a video.
Oh my God, Joel.
All right.
Well, all right.
Let's do it, dude.
Let's, let's end it here.
Let's call it a wrap and, uh, and I'll go troubleshoot your instance.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
All right, dude.
This is a good episode.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord.
Join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you
access to masterclasses, AMAs, hackalongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel
with us.
We'll see you there.